smiley face ah smiley face
got some smiles in the chat i think i'll
start playing the daily horde arena
um i played the horde the other day it
was fun
i played against an fm i lost but
um it's an interesting variant i'll
leave a link in the chat in case people
want to join
i actually have a tick tock um
the question is if i want to be more
active on tick tock
because i only have a couple a couple
videos posted on tik tok
uh i guess this whole time i'll just be
pushing pawns
[Music]
trade some stuff keep pushing
um i've considered it
the the main focus is twitching youtube
but tiktok
also facebook um there's some other
platforms which i might
might look into we probably have to
start outsourcing
that type of work though
to do here i don't know any horde theory
i'm just kind of winging it
playing on the wing um
opponent wants to take i don't want to
allow the the sack
so take here
and then keep pushing maybe this move
actually i have a question can pawns
on the second rate move two squares
forward i assume so
but what about on the first rank
i guess i'll find out also that's a good
move
oh i might be in trouble uh let's
push or
that should be okay okay so pawns can
move two squares
also j steel thanks for gifting subs
appreciate that
yeah so i'm gonna try and stay solid
i'm a little bit scared though
[Music]
i got to start pushing more center pawns
yeah i'm actually really scared here
because white's kind of breaking through
or how blocked blocks breaking through
let's keep pushing
maybe this move
thanks everyone for subbing oh test
naming door
also welcome back subscribing through
august
august is only a few months away
oh man this is this is already pretty
rough
i feel like i got out prepped
um i'm also about to flag let's push
this pawn
i want to go for some mating attack ouch
oh no my pawns
okay let's go for g6
yeah welcome back everyone if you're
just joining this is horde
um also my time my time is quite low
at least i have i'm playing on the dark
squares basically
okay let's play this move going for this
move
does cheb mean oh like chess but with
bees
okay this is actually looking
interesting now
have this move and then this move
threatening e6
e6 is hard to stop actually
i have another idea too to play c6 and
then no probably e6
first
try and reinforce everything
ah
i'm gonna try and stay focused here
i think f6 is a best free move
okay this should be winning actually but
do i have enough time to convert
four seconds
actually i don't know if it's winning
oh no it's not winning
no why did black take there
i could have queened
ah
no my pawns
ah oh black was taking a long time
here i was expecting this move
or no uh it was here yeah i was
expecting this move
and then it takes i could have queened
and traded queens and then won
but what to do did my heart rate go up i
wasn't looking
is that 89 what's a normal heart rate
actually don't know
it went to 101 really wow
so i wonder how many calories i don't
know if it tells me how many calories
i'm burning
hey happy seven months welcome back
singapore back hammond
normal is 69 are you trolling me or
oh 60 to 90. ah
nice okay um let's go back to
tournaments maybe i'll play the whole
thing
i have to recover after that yeah i
finally got around to connecting
because i have an apple watch and
there's an app that
that basically connects the heart rate
with overlay
i i took a run last week when i was
running my heart rate was like one
160 170.
oh those are okay all biz work back
so i need to basically take all the
pawns within 90 seconds to win this
good evening tasmanian sea puma welcome
back
okay so on the sack here d5 never mind
um let's try and chip away
so time management is really important
because there's no
increment let's take care
yeah there goes my knight
oh a lot of people a lot of
uh pre babies celebrating the trimester
okay this is now really nice because
this pawn
can't be defended i'm guaranteed to open
the a file
and then the rook will go bananas oh
oops okay white's just pre-moving
and giving me
yeah it's hard to defend the pawns when
i attack from behind
i think for the rest of the game every
single move i play
will be upon capture
wants to draw maybe miss click the
resign button
okay let's go back oh so in order to
join the tournament you need to have
played at least
15 rated horde games which maybe is not
the case for
everyone what's your schedule like
also it's 3 41 am here
oh you're probably in europe then right
i'm putting it there just so it's
um people want to look at me they can
don't have to to move their eyes long
distances
um yeah i don't have a set streaming
schedule
um at least for most my streams so the
best way to catch streams is to follow
on twitch
and then you can get notified when i go
live um
generally i'll stream a handful of times
per week
usually like three to five times on a
normal week
actually i haven't been feeling so well
the last few days
like the the spring marathon took a lot
out of me
i've been having some like neck pain
back pain
so i've been taking it easy okay this
pawn is a
kind of the target
f6 not super comfortable
hey eric i'm new to chess mainly because
of your youtube channel
oh welcome depressed for you and your
channel streaming
appreciate that well welcome to the
twitch stream
yeah shout out to all the new viewers
there's always new people and tuning
into the stream it's nice to see
um what to do here i'm actually a little
bit stuck
maybe i'll just bring the king
in and see what white is up to
maybe i'll um play queen e8 and then
target c6
not super pleasant though
[Music]
um
okay trying to fight for something white
could on passant
but then i take and attack two
undefended pawns
if i it doesn't on passant then
okay this is good and there's some
pressure there
oh that defends everything forgot about
that move
okay let's just trade
and hold my ground this might be
difficult
okay i think that was a mistake from
white because i have uh i had three
defenders
what to do
in this move
so i want to target the b-pawn i can
move
okay now i want to target the a pawn
put the bpm icon over your heart on the
live cam for extra realism
uh i'm gonna hold off for now
interesting suggestion though
i gotta focus not i'm not flagging here
um
[Music]
now what do i do here
oh no
ah
okay there we go i'm still in big
trouble but this
this offers some hope
hey it's rain hey it's nemo what's up
nemo
if you're just joining i'm trying to
take all my opponent's pawns in less
than 10 seconds
um shout out to nemo someone give nemo
shout out i think we have a nemo command
too oh i was gonna learn polish
because i had the thought the other day
if nemo reads me i would want to just
start speaking polish but i forgot to
learn polish
okay i might just go for a dirty flag
and then dedicate it to nemo
hey this is dave thanks for gifting subs
alexa say something nice and polish
oh alexa volume eight
alexa say something nice and polish
something nice in polishes
wait show me
i don't know sorry for butchering your
language
but shout out aka nam sko
um for those with joining or playing
horde
it's uh it's a fun variant white starts
with a lot of pawns
um because white's a hoarder and
the goal for white is to mate the goal
for black is to
take all the pawns or the goal for
either players to dirty flag the other
player
so um okay
oh i'm playing i'm playing oh this is
probably a strong player
and they're berserking me i don't want
to berserk back
i want my time anyone who names their
username after the variant is probably
really strong in that variant
also thinks this is dave gifting more
subs
shout out to dave also i have no
idea what the theory is here
uh let's just push stuff
hope for the best
i already feel like i'm getting
outplayed
um interesting so if i push
it doesn't quite work
[Music]
i don't know what to do let's just push
like this and then like
this
oh they're gonna do man this is what my
first opponent did to me
i think i'm in trouble um
potentially it's a lot to organize
um so i would need i would need
assistance like it's not the type of
thing i can just do on my own
so it takes more setup let's
take and play this
hey it's a fork a black is about to
destroy me
um
i'm uncomfortable here
f4 before we trade
maybe that's the way to go though
so pawns on the first frame can move two
squares forward
i'm in really big trouble though
um man
let's start pushing the each pawn no
play this
i'm already down on time that's so sad
um
[Music]
play this move small trap with this move
lock's not falling for any traps
i'm a little bit hopeful here not super
[Music]
hopeful
okay threatening this now
these pawns are clunky
that's a fork
no yes
no wait what happens here
i lost oh i lost because i lost all my
pawns oh
even though black only has a king i
don't have a king oh that's kind of sad
ah okay
i feel like a beginner at this game like
i know how the pawn moves
i don't know like so much strategy
man okay maybe i'll get like
one more game in
oh karen kk oh yeah i didn't get a
chance to look at your game on
stream but i saw uh karen kk
played ludwig played a stafford gamut
against the ludwig
wait played a staffer gambit against
ludwig what did i say
it was a cool game um
some yeah some fireworks
maybe at some point like i can show it
but first things first is to uh to
finish off this tournament
so it seems like the strategy is to push
like create the tension go for the
trades
and then try and
like create the the battery
i already go wrong
maybe f6 i just want to trade stuff
oh i i said against ludwig
have to work on my my articles
um okay let's take
so i want to build the how do i do this
this move i'll admit i don't know what
i'm doing
i'm just going for pawn trades
hmm
fiance the bishop
okay so maybe here
i can play this move and this move
so i'm gonna go for the same idea
that these other people used against me
here we go dave this is dave gifting
another five thanks dave
drifting tamsha panther egg
nolo t luffy and i blinks
okay i like the looks of this
i guess i'm still like it still takes
work to crack
the position
huh
this move you're cool
oh you're cool too move zig
maybe this move so i want to take and
then take
and then hope that i don't get smushed
here we go okay so this is where the
the all yuki buffet begins
oh okay these pawns are actually
sort of menacing take this first
this move i want to eventually connect
the rook
to guard the back rank
take take take take steak
[Music]
play play this move
and white's getting a lot of tempe on my
things
oh wait that was a blunder okay that was
a key pawn too
it's still not over though a lot of
pawns to capture
man that's going to be one annoying
vaughn chain
um also my time
this move
okay
a little bit scared
14 seconds i don't know about this
weird position
king bishop
oh no
oh no
is there stalemate in this game there
might be stalemate
well played for my opponent though i
wasn't quick enough to take the pawns
also the tournament's over good job so
the hoarding holder
uh winning the tournament beating me in
the process
what to do